hey 42 here on the 1st of May 1960 a
Soviet s75 to Vena surface-to-air
missile and smashed into an American U2
spy Play Somewhere over the region as
third loss
not wanting to lose face either in front
of the press or the Soviets the U.S
government can cut to the cover story
claiming the plane was a NASA research
craft that went down after getting into
difficulties
they really went to town trying to make
the deception as plausible as possible
explaining that the pilot had radioed in
a problem with his oxygen supply shortly
before contact with the plane was lost
they even went so far as to ground the
U.S Air Force's entire fleet of u2s
ostensibly to check the oxygen Delivery
Systems for faults it was an excellent
piece of deception delivered
convincingly but there was one small
problem
actually there were two really [ __ ]
massive problems
first the planes pilot Gary Powers had
not as the Americans believed died in
the crash he dejected safely and was in
the custody of the Soviets secondly the
U2 spy plane which was covered in more
high-tech reconnaissance gear than a
billionaire stalker had survived the
missile strike with relatively minor
damage and the Soviets could see all too
clearly that this was no research craft
seeing an opportunity to score a point
against their Cold War Rivals the
Soviets wasted no time parading both the
pilot and large chunks of the spy plane
in front of the world's press to make
matters even worse the two superpowers
had been due to meet for peace talks at
a Paris Summit just weeks after the
plane was shut down with the Americans
made to look like mugs for planting such
a public lie and the Soviets Furious
that the Americans were spying on them
right before the peace talks the summit
was canceled and a cold war continued
unabated for the next 30 Years
all in all the whole thing was a bit of
a disaster for everyone involved but
there was one rather nice knock-on
effect
the 1960 U2 incident directly led to the
development of what many people believe
is the greatest airplane ever built
that's a pretty bold claim but if you
watch the end of this video trust me
you're going to agree this is the story
of the Lockheed SR-71 Blackbird the
Invincible spy plane
a VPN keeps you safe and private whilst
covering up everything you do online and
surfsharkvpn lets you travel the world
virtually by changing your virtual
location or if you're actually
physically traveling surfshark lets you
connect via your home country so you
don't miss out on your home Comforts
such as streaming video content from
home that might be blocked whilst you're
traveling there are over 3 200 servers
in 100 countries so anywhere you go
you'll find a server that fits your
needs surfsharkvpn offers a multi-hub
feature so you can put two VPN servers
between you and your online destination
for even more privacy and security and I
love surf sharks IP Rotator feature
which constantly changes your device's
IP address without losing your VPN
connection it's just really important to
stay safe online whilst you're out and
about and that's why I use surfsharkvpn
so I can for example access my online
banking safely even on public Wi-Fi
there's no chance I'd ever do that
without
vpns also keep your location and
download history private so you can send
and receive files securely quite simply
surfsharkvpn is an essential tool and by
using the Code 42 you'll benefit from an
83 discount plus free extra months for
free all you have to do is click the
special link in the description below so
don't miss out and thanks to surfshark
for sponsoring this video
when the U2 first flew in 1955 the US
government believed its lofty 70 000
foot cruising altitude put it out of
range of Soviet radar systems as Gary
Powers proved in 1960 that very much
wasn't the case
in fact Soviet radar technology was far
more advanced than the Americans had
ever imagined and that was a serious
problem the Lockheed U2 was relatively
slow with a large radar cross-section if
the Soviets could successfully track it
it was nothing more than a very
expensive flying duck
the CIA invested serious cash trying to
make the U2 less visible to radar but
when those efforts failed it became
clear they were going to need a new
plane entirely one that would truly be
invulnerable to Soviet air defense
systems
of course building an invincible
airplane was impossible but it just so
happens that the Americans had an
aeronautical engineer who'd built a
career out of making the impossible
possible his name was Kelly Johnson and
to give you an idea of the length and
importance of his career I can tell you
that he designed the United States first
jet fighter the first military aircraft
to fly faster than 400 miles per hour
the first Mach 2 capable fighter and the
first aircraft ever to exceed Mach 3.
put simply he is one of the most
important figures in the entire history
of Aviation at the time he was head of
lockheed's advanced development projects
her Department better known by its
nickname the Skunk Works Johnson's team
was relatively small but comprised some
of the finest aerospace engineering
Minds not just in the US but the entire
world together Johnson and his merry
band of geniuses came up with a plane
that can only be described as a miracle
of engineering
the first iteration of that aircraft was
known as the a12 and it was like nothing
that had ever been built before it was
developed under a cloak of absolute
secrecy and first took to the skies in
the early 60s where it was tested at
some place called Groom Lake though you
might know it by another name area 51.
it was this plane and others like it
that helped build area 51's reputation
as the home of secret alien technology
and it isn't hard to imagine why the a12
wouldn't have looked out of place in a
Ridley Scott space epic
by the way if the name a12 sounds
familiar you might be thinking of one of
Elon musk's children whose called
um
uh yeah I've no idea the a12 part of
this poor kids designation is a tribute
to musk's favorite plane the SR-71 which
is ultimately what the a12 became
to begin with there are three different
variants the regular a12 was a straight
up reconnaissance play but there was
also an Interceptor the yf-12 that was
equipped with air-to-air missiles and
the particularly badass M21 which came
with a detachable unmanned drone
but none of these planes ever really
well took off because waiting in the
wings was the a12 successor the SR-71
nicknamed Blackbird for its striking
paint job although little known fact
time that paint was actually an
extremely dark shade of blue capable of
cruising 16 miles above the surface of
the Earth at more than three times the
speed of sound the SR-71 was the perfect
spy play it was one of the first built
with a stealth design that dramatically
reduced its radar signature and it flew
so high and so fast that ground fire
couldn't touch it
by the time Soviet radar systems locked
on and some installations fired it was
simply too late the sr-721 was long gone
during three decades of active service
an estimated 4 000 surface-to-air
missiles were fired at the SR-71
not a single one hit its mark
the Blackbird was such a revolutionary
aircraft that almost the entire thing
had to be built from scratch using new
technology
air temperatures at cruising altitude
were in the region of minus 85 degrees
Celsius but the SR-71 flew so fast that
friction with the thin atmosphere
generated temperatures have Beyond 300
degrees Celsius across its frame when a
blackbird landed after a flight at Mach
3 its Hull was so hot you could cook
your dinner on it although I'm pretty
sure that was frowned upon
regular Aviation aluminum would begin to
soften if exposed to such extreme heat
so the SR-71 was built almost entirely
from a titanium alloy that was something
that had never been done before and a
whole new set of fabrication tools and
methods had to be invented before they
could even start the incredible heat
generated when this plane was cruising
at almost three and a half times the
speed of sound caused other problems too
the airframe expanded by almost a foot
as it warmed so all the planes panels
had to be fitted with plenty of play
that extra wiggle room meant the SR-71
steadily leaked fuel whilst on the
ground because the fuel tanks didn't
seal properly incidentally there
happened to be a bit of a shortage of
titanium in the us at the time which was
particularly unfortunate because the
vast majority of the global Supply came
from the Soviet Union
buying direct clearly wasn't an option
so the CIA had to establish a number of
dummy corporations to get skunk worked
what they needed the first sr-71s went
into service in 1966 about seven months
before the England football team won the
World Cup which is completely irrelevant
but it's always nice to mention it in
total there were 32 sr-71s made these
planes flew so high that Pilots had to
wear special pressure suits to prevent
their blood from boiling in their veins
if the cockpit's Integrity happens to be
breached and that incredible altitude
meant the SR-71 could go where it
pleased though so far as we know none
were ever actually flown over the Soviet
Union by this point in the Cold War
tensions were simply too high to risk it
and besides the Blackbird could do a
surprisingly good job at Gathering
reconnaissance even from outside of
Soviet airspace the planes were equipped
with side-facing cameras that could scan
100
000 square miles of enemy territory in a
single hour
for almost 30 years the SR-71 ruled the
skies an Untouchable Phantom that would
occasionally coalesce on enemy Radars
before disappearing Into The Ether
we'll likely never know which missions
were flown and where but it's fought
that sr-71s were used all over the world
and in almost every major warso
but by the 1990s the use case for this
most impressive machine was beginning to
look a little shaky for all its
technological Brilliance the SR-71 had
one fatal flaw it lacked a live data
feed meaning any intelligence it
gathered couldn't be analyzed until the
craft was back at base
the existing planes could always have
been upgraded sure but emerging
Technologies like spy satellites and
unmanned drones could do the same job
more efficiently in the end a
combination of these new technologies
politics and the phenomenal running
costs of the SR-71 saw it retired though
plenty of senior figures in the Air
Force considered that move to be a grave
mistake after all Spy satellites could
be slow to get into position and
unmanned drone technology we're still in
its infancy but after briefly being
brought out of retirement in 1999 the
SR-71 was mothballed for good shortly
afterwards
the Blackbird is a relic from another
era a spy plane built almost 60 years
ago that's long since being replaced by
newer more advanced models replaced but
never surpassed to this day the SR-71
Remains the fastest air-breathing
airplane ever built and it still holds
numerous point-to-point records
including the fastest flight from New
York to London in 1974 it made a journey
in one hour 54 minutes a full hour
faster than supersonic speed demon
Concord there's something almost
mythical about this airplane
those who built it talked about it in
hushed tones and the pilots who flew it
were simply in awe in the words of U.S
Air Force Colonel Jim Watkins at 85 000
feet on mag-free it was almost a
religious experience
if you want to see an SR-71 for yourself
today your only chance is to visit one
of the select few museums around the
world that were lucky enough to get one
but here's the good news a successor is
in the works commonly referred to as son
of Blackbird the sr-72 could fly as
early as 2025.
as for whether it will live up to the
legacy of its progenitor only time will
tell
[Music]
thanks for watching